ville e con la voglia che ciò di
registrare questo video delle palle
potevo fare quello che programmava le
casse i supermercati non l'ho io più
bello fare facevano di più per sette non
dite niente di niente sono già incassato
non ancora registrata mente sono già
incassato continua getting over i tre
grazie però rimasti che è bello che non
vedevo proprio l'ora
la cosa fantastica ragazze che a milano
sta nevicando quindi è già miracolo sta
cosa che non si non vedo la neve da una
vita e mezza facciamo andiamo a
guardarla neve fuori la ministra noi
giochiamo a getting over it che un bel
gioco di un pizzo su una pentola in una
pentola che tenta di raggiungere i
luoghi mente una scala e non ci riesce
porca la mia schifosa voglia di vivere
se cado l'inizio da capo tra i video
servite a niente
o mio dio un'ora per riuscire a fare
questa cosa perfetto non perfetto ma
allora l'ultimo scalino ma salvato non
so se vi rendete conto del disagio
perfetto siamo arrivati alla telecamera
ora dovrebbe essere più semplice perché
che no non mi ricordo assolutamente una
volta arrivato qui già ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo rafa mi non guardate questo
video
mamma mia che disastro
tutto storto l'hanno fatto suo livello
io ve lo giuro io non posso avere io
credo che comunque ci sia un limite cav
h no ma è così difficile per delle
scuole madonna neanche mio nonno ok puoi
andare su senza tornare indietro ogni
tre secondi a nocivo libertà non è vero
nella vita a questa tastiera sembra guè
pequeno il tizio capito o no non è vero
ti prego ok no ma salvata videocamera ma
come avevo fatto le prime volte madonna
ma perché non riesco più solo sul sangue
e il mio problema nel non riuscire più a
fare questa cosa che una volta mi che
sono uscito in tre secondi
oh mio dio
voglio uno ho bisogno guarda un orgasmo
si no madonna no no no
gesù ha mai fatto niente l'ispra sa
sempre un bravo ragazzo perché mi tifare
sclerare così perché deve esistere
questo gioco dello schifo in terra o dio
mio
adesso viene la parte lasciamo per
allora via dalle balle bene seccato qua
a sinistra si riparte dalla piscina e
noi non vogliamo ripartire dalla piscina
no che non lo vogliamo l'ultima volta
sono caduto quindi piano si no poi su
questo ammazzo ti ammazzo ai sub bravo
bravissimo ok ok no
il simpatico questo giorno
fermi e zitti non zitti piano
[Musica]
metti il tuo culo li culo no bene ok
frega niente se non sono arrivato un
metro dal cadere giù non è possibile
nella vita non è possibile allora porca
di una vacca laida intrisa nel
ok basta c'è cosa mi chiedevo fare
adesso fermi ok c'è stampante racz è un
pollice in su cosa perché c'è un pollice
in su li mettete gli piace il video se
siete arrivati fino a questo punto
perché io ci sono arrivato fino a questo
punto quindi mi piace doveroso ad dopo
poi al pollice devo prendermi che ne so
io dal pollice vado su bene c'era un
jump scherzo sto gioco di me c'era
veramente un jobs che andate a cagare
sono riuscito
sono riuscito a sopravvivere nonostante
il job schiera e quello che mi si è
incastrato il martello a ce la fai
andare oltre per favore grazie gentile
agi gis ci siamo roccia dall'estero
semplice in teoria
[Musica]
gesù è successo questa musica è partita
a perché ci dovrebbe essere il narratore
di sottofondo che ho tolto perché dalla
dal menu l'abbiamo tolto l'altra l'altra
volta per in da fastidio allora siamo
arrivati davanti a un cespuglio quadrato
se riuscisse a superare questo teo che
possiamo dare ancora un po più in alto
ma ganna sponda ok che cosa piace una
montagna ma siete scemi anno montagna di
ghiaccio
va bene che c'è un cartello rosalie come
ci arrivo aiuto da eva peron tigro pare
il cappello piano piano piano piano
piano non c'è il cappello di mezzo mi dà
fastidio
orca vacca è caduto giù è caduto giù il
cappello fermi qualcuno mi esplichi la
situazione per cortesia cioè quel gancio
lì no no però una domanda una domanda
molto semplice io vedo che qua c'è un
baratro che infermi no no no mi piace
sta roba
non l'ho preso e stato bruttissimo
michia checa gas e tornava all'inizio
del gioco sarebbe stata no perché il suo
gioco ne sarebbe capace ha quindi non
devo prendere il gancio che dovà a dove
arriva direttamente lì va bene ok va
bene almeno si sa quanto state facendo
sudore cosa devo fare qua aiuto madonna
quanto difficile
è che palle madonna rega impossibile
aiuto morgan non ci arrivo aiuto cosa da
fare qui perché partono le musiche a
perché in teoria c'è il narratore che
narra a me ne frega molto in questo
momento del narratore che sta narrando
la reding stato fare qua avevano preso
fenomeno fu grande
vabbè fare quasi una cabina del telefono
aiuto sono delle pen
ci sono delle pentole tipo quella che vi
addosso solo che sono un po più vere
devo fare qua scusata non capito non è
vero non è che devo andare sulla palla
sinistra adesso significa a farsene
andare là sopra a devo lanciarmi dalla
collina ok armeno fa qualcosa nella tua
vita
ok e vabbè un fenomeno un fenomeno però
termoli six ok sto andando anche bene in
questo video a differenza degli altri
però non troppo vere non troppo bene
cosa devo fare che vado saltato da tra
sponda sì però mamma mia mamma mia a un
giocatore è un fenomeno oggi un fenomeno
un certo oggi sono stato veramente bravo
rispetto all'altro una botta di culo
incredibile waves e interisti hyundai è
stata ambition a parlarmi romanico tolto
la la voce alla
non cavalcare il serpente vuoi un po di
questo a posso andare pure con un
secchio ma si può andar lì su aspetta un
attimo
no non saprei come ho fatto per cava cà
fermo lì ma fa il salto decente bello
secco ragazza cinema ok ok piano di
nuovo degli spiriti così o no ma
tornasse cadevo ok perfetto
ok ok piano su sopra
bene oggi ma siamo sicuri che io debba
aver chiesto giocando a cotanto schifo
so solo io cosa devo fare qua scusate ma
non è possibile arrivare fin lì non è
capito spingere con questo ma forse no
non so dove vai da lì ma non importa non
non lo farò che a bacca michele
inusabile scivolare di brutto sto coso e
inusabile col secchio alla fine c'è
ufficio più propulsione col 6 mancava
ma scusate ma